I want to start off by telling you
something okay you are the first black
female they make a force under 30.
really hard to
be in 2022 so
I want to be bigger than just my music
like I want people to know Megan as
everything that she ever wanted to be
Megan the artist I feel like I've always
liked to Dibble and dab in a lot of
different things and I feel like I got
that from my mom and my dad my dad was a
street guy uh he was an entrepreneur he
had his own clothing line my mother like
I watched her go to work to her nine to
five every day and come home and write
songs and take me to the studio and be a
mom and be a just a good woman in
general like it was just like a long
line of like women that I saw work and
just do everything that they wanted to
do and still pour into me that I could
be making a style and I could be
creative I could be making a student I'm
gonna give my degree my big mama she
didn't care about me rapping she was
just like you gonna get that degree and
I'm like I am gonna get my degree I had
two plan A's rapping was not a plan B
and school was not a plan B now I feel
like my mind is just like that my mind
is in a place where I feel like I can do
whatever I want to do because nobody
ever told me good absolutely so getting
into writing uh getting into directing
getting into acting I feel like yeah now
y'all see I'm not one-dimensional I'm
everything that I say I am
so tell me you know the new CD or new
project is dropped I'm old school I
still say CCD okay all right yes your
project I'm selling CDs too yeah and
also what's it been like this album was
really personal to me this is like the
first time I ever you know talked about
things that I'm feeling or talked about
things that I'm going through so it kind
of made me nervous to you know write a
lot of these songs it makes me nervous
to perform some of these songs and I
kind of just was like okay I'm gonna
write this stuff and I'm just put it out
what you got to say about this my
emotions sometimes make me a little
nervous like to be vulnerable can make
me a little nervous sometimes so
I don't know I feel like I'm just still
processing how the album feels to other
people yeah so I did two meet and greets
one in New York and one in California
and all of the hotties were coming up to
me like Megan I relate to anxiety so
much Megan I relate to ungrateful Megan
the you made this song for me and I'm
like oh wow it made me feel happy that
the time I did decide to be vulnerable
and talk about something I was going
through it was one of the favorites from
all of my fans and I really appreciate
it and they made me feel comfortable
like okay it is it's okay to not be okay
and it's okay to tell y'all I'm not okay
what's the biggest thing you've learned
about the business side of Music save
your money like
I still haven't made a stupid crazy
purchase like my jewelry is expensive
and my house was expensive but like
outside of that I'm not buying a hundred
cars like as soon as I start getting
money I spend it on school yeah like and
then when I got done paying for school
then that's when I started like buying
chains and like stuff like that but like
you should learn about how to make your
money work for you I feel like that was
important for me to share with other
people that are like my age and other
black kids like because I feel like
sometimes when you think about investing
the terminology that people use it makes
it sound so hard like and I feel like
when you're talking to your homegirl and
when you're talking to somebody that you
can understand and speak the same
language okay well I I understand that I
can get into investing too so I feel
like it was important for me to talk to
my fans about it because you you will
understand it coming out of my mouth go
back to your younger self right maybe
before it blew maybe before you got the
you know record deal all that what do
you tell your younger self knowing what
you know now go back in time what are
you talking young people you need to
keep doing exactly what you're doing
because this is gonna pay off girl like
do not stop dancing in the mirror do not
stop writing songs don't stop stealing
your mama uh instrumentals I would just
tell myself keep doing you because
it's gonna pay him
[Music]